here's Korean jump here with an abject
100 lie go the mall yesterday you guys
reported on it who have condemned uh
this false depiction of the
unprecedented violent attack on cons on
our Constitution and the rule of law
which caused police police officers
their lives and that's what we saw in
that day on a very dark day an attack on
our democracy caused police officers
their lives uh actually one police
officer did die Days Later of a heart
attack right it was a heart attack Brian
sydnick okay but it did not cost police
officers their lives they did not take
anyone hostage they did not waterboard
anybody or anything like that so this is
just what they do with everything but
now what I want to link this to is how
the lies get laundered through the
machine so you have late night hosts
just abject lying and just mocking the
guy for putting out what most people
would just say should be just be public
information if this was the Insurrection
of all time how about we just see the
video and everyone can decide what level
of insanity this was and what should be
done about it right like if you guys
want to make your case why are you the
ones that need to hide the information
to make your case right so you got a guy
like Colbert who does his version of the
lie you have Corinne Jean-Pierre who
does her version of the lie you have
Chuck and you have McConnell who are
agreeing nobody should see any of this
and we should probably pressure the
people to make sure that the guy who's
releasing this doesn't even get on
television tonight I mean that's
absolutely extraordinary that Chuck said
that so it's the government and the
media working together and they somehow
are always working together against you
which is starting to become a problem if
you ask me
foreign
[Music]